i'll be honest with you guys new pokemon
snap can be really cryptic sometimes
i found myself stuck and not knowing how
to progress numerous times but after
beating the game i noticed there were
specific things that usually advance
the story even if the game doesn't tell
you so in an effort to help my fellow
photographers i wanted to break down
things you can try if you find yourself
stuck
in new pokemon snap if you like this
video then consider dropping a like and
subscribing
we'd appreciate it so first things first
let's talk about research levels
when you complete a course your photos
will be evaluated by professor mir and
you'll get a score on those photos
that score becomes expedition points and
you'll need a certain amount of
expedition points to unlock the next
research level in any given course
a new research level means more pokemon
and potential new behaviors for the
pokemon that were already there
what the game doesn't tell you is that a
lot of the time you need to get to
research level 2 to advance the story
and at least for me i didn't always get
to research level 2 my first time around
so i needed to go through the course
again to get more expedition points
as a little bonus tip to that you should
still snap pokemon you've already
snapped when going through a course
again
and having the professor evaluate them
for expedition points even though it
won't increase your photo decks it'll
help you get to the next research level
faster
you never need to get past level 2 on
any of the courses if you're just trying
to beat the main story
but i do want to point out that at one
point in the game you get the option to
take photos around the lab and you do
not need to get the level 2 on that one
the expedition points required for that
one is a lot larger than the regular
courses and it has no bearing on the
story so don't be like me
and play that course a dozen times only
for nothing to happen before i move on i
want to briefly mention that you'll
reach a point where you start getting
requests from your team members
and while they're a great way to get
some four-star photos they have nothing
to do with story progression so if
you're stuck
don't start trying to do a bunch of
requests like i also did so okay
you have every main course up to
research level two and you still haven't
progressed
now what can you do well try lumen orbs
to unlock some lumen orbs you'll need to
take a photo of the glowing crystal
bloom on each island
yes there's a different colored lumina
orb for each island that only works on
that island
you must take a photo of a glowing
crystal bloom once that aren't glowing
don't count
and then once you do that the professor
will be able to make the new lumina orbs
for that island
sometimes that'll be enough to progress
but if that doesn't work
try going through the course again and
actually using the illumina orbs
sometimes the professor just wants to
see it in action and i respect that
this next part is going to get a little
more specific to later parts of the game
so if you haven't gotten through the
forest lumina spot yet i'd recommend
getting to that point with the
information i've already given and then
coming back
alright so you've gotten to that point
in the game great this is where things
get
super cryptic after you've taken photos
of the second luminous pokemon you'll
learn that there are more luminous
pokemon
two more to be specific but how do you
get to them the game tells you nothing
so here's what you have to do to get the
first one you'll need to play research
level 2 of the volcano because it leads
down a completely separate path
not an alternate path it just is a
separate path
how would you know to do this you
wouldn't so hopefully you just felt like
playing the volcano level again
but once you start volcano level 2 it's
pretty straightforward the other one is
probably the most frustrating and also
probably why a lot of you are here
in c4 level two you'll notice that claw
its are at the beginning of the level
it'll start swimming in front of you and
you'll notice it try to destroy some
rocks in a cave but it isn't strong
enough to do it
what you're supposed to do is hit this
pokemon with a lumina orb and that
powers it up so it'll destroy the rocks
and open a new path to you
you'll need to take a photo of the
glowing crystal bloom in the sea floor
and unlock the lumina ore before
attempting this
this gameplay mechanic was never used
before and is never used again
so if you didn't know to do that i do
not blame you at all from there just
follow the new path and you'll be on
your way to the fourth lumen of pokemon
moving on once you reach the cave on the
fifth island it's actually similar to
the third lumen of pokemon in the
volcano
just play through research level 2
normally after you unlock it and it'll
lead down a new path
now beyond this is endgame spoilers so
if you haven't unlocked the sixth and
final island
come back once you do in the final area
ruins of remembrance
you first want to get the glowing
crystal bloom which is actually very
close to the beginning of the course
once you do that and professor mira
creates this island's lumen orb
go through the course again and this
time light up all the flowers in the
cave itself
they can be pretty tricky to spot and
make sure you hit them before the neo1
gets too far away or you'll have to
start the course over once you do that a
new route will unlock and you'll be on
your way to the final lumen of pokemon
and there you have it hopefully this
helped you progress through some of the
more cryptic parts of new pokemon snap
have any further questions drop them
down in the comments below and i'll try
to answer them as best as i can
if you're curious to see the differences
between pokemon snap and new pokemon
snap i made another video listing off
six of the biggest changes between the
two
thanks for watching and for all things
pokemon stay tuned to gamespot
[Music]
you